aujourd'hui lundi nous retrouvons la
chronique culturelle de sephora namani
sephora bonsoir bonsoir fait longtemps
qu'on n'a pas fait un troyen que
culturelles devraient se moquer et oui
aujourd'hui je vais vous présenter le
festival métal open sphère qui aura lieu
à saint quentin en yvelines vendredi et
samedi prochain exactement alors le
festival métal open ce faire est une
première édition organisée par
l'association vie chinoise métal à ceux
qui oeuvrent pour la promotion des
musiques amplifiées dans le département
yvelinois et plus particulièrement sur
saint quentin il mène différentes
actions comme l'accompagnement de
groupes locaux et bien sûr par ailleurs
organise des concerts et festivals
alors ils ont organisé d'ailleurs deux
éditions en 2013 en 2014 d'un festival
qui s'appelait métal ce thème et à se
faire pardonner qui avait lieu en
extérieur jeu que vous êtes très au
courant vous aimez le métal florennes je
ne connais pas très bien en fait ah bon
alors on va s'y intéresser ensemble donc
cette année aura lieu la première
édition en intérieur en partenariat avec
le café de la plage de maurepas pierre
michel planchon coordinateur de mets ta
sauce nous en dit plus l'idée de
proposer un événement voilà faits
marquants durant cette saison autour de
l'esthétique métal vous voulez une
programmation plutôt éclectique dans le
genre voilà très ouverts d'où le open
c'est quand même le métal s'instille où
il ya plein de sous genres de pas mal de
choses donc on voulait que ce soit assez
représentative de nine et d'ouverture
voilà un peu fraternité entre les
différentes choses ça libe ouverture aux
autres et diversité culturelle et
programmation éclectique vous l'avez
compris sont les maîtres mots
il y aura donc du métal progressif du
corps du trash de l'instrumental du
stoner du death et de l'acoustique
ça fait beaucoup donc il y aura neuf
groupes différents qui vont jouer sur
deux jours le vendredi 6 mai au café de
la paix de la plage à maurepas à partir
de 20 heures ou samedi à la salle de la
tour sur voisins le bretonneux à partir
de 18 heures voilà c'est ça dont chacun
fera un passage de 45 minutes à une
heure et parmi ces groupes nous
retrouverons le groupe oracle que nous
avions d'ailleurs reçu sur le plateau du
kiosque qui propose du death progressif
ou encore le groupe drouot avec un métal
acoustique
voilà
non
moi
en accord
alors de rentrer le groupe que l'on
vient d'écouter d'ailleurs le groupe
parrainé cette année par l'association
met ta sauce alors parmi ces neuf
groupes qu'est ce qu'on va retrouver des
groupes locaux des invités alors
principalement des groupes locaux élite
et élite et aidants de promouvoir les
groupes yvelinois come back in time with
gazoline qui est un groupe
ramboll éteint il y aura également deux
têtes d'affiché deux invités à
reconnaissance nationale comme le groupe
erin länder
erin des donc groupe toulousain connu
pour sa vision avant-gardiste et
expérimentale du métal est donc la
deuxième tête d'affiché ce sera the
walking dead orchestra groupe grenoblois
cette fois ci à la reconnaissance
nationale et internationale l'un des
groupes vraiment phare de la scène du
des scores français
ce jour
aucun rapport avec la série the walking
dead dont le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est que c'est assez énergique comme
musique voilà c'est ça énergique c'est
vrai que le métal se caractérise par un
son lourd dé sont souvent saturées au
niveau de la guitare une rythmique
rapide pour la batterie certains parlent
même de violence dans la musique et puis
ce chiant un peu éraillée comme ça qui
est vraiment la signature rock du métal
alors on pourrait croire que le chanteur
lui hurle simplement mais bien au
contraire ça relève d'une technique de
chant très avancées en métal par son
champ un peu voilà saturé on dit ce
qu'on a ça braille maintenant c'est
vraiment une technique particulière
donc c'est quand même assez marquant
d'identité c'est une technique va de
respiration en fait qui a avancé m'ont
compris müller en fait ne fait bouger
les muqueuses de la gorge
donc c'est pas genre à ce gars là dessus
c'est vraiment une technique voilà de
chant qui joue beaucoup sur la
respiration sur son contrôle de soi eh
bien merci à ces foires nous avoir fait
découvrir le métal alors je le rappelle
le festival métal aux peines l'air aura
lieu le vendredi 6 mai à partir de 20
heures au café de la plage de maurepas
et samedi 7 mai à partir de 18h à la
salle de la tour de
voisins-le-bretonneux plus
d'informations sur la fiche qui
s'adresse votre affirmation votre écran
ça fera plaisir à notre liste de camille
lambert merci beaucoup